ladies and gentlemen your boy Nick
Swisher filling in for Rich Eisen on the
Rich Eisen show stoked to be here I'm
with my man Marty fish happy to have you
here my man everything's good bro you're
doing alright yeah okay well so we were
actually talking and we actually need to
ask you this we need to know exactly
what a u.s. Davis Cup captain does right
you replace you replace Courier Yeah
right and just on the outside looking in
bro like what an honor to do something
that's a huge honor it's a dream job no
doubt about it as far as tennis go as
far as retired American tennis player
that's kind of the gig that I wanted
ever since I played Davis Cup which is
our team event really our only team
event in tennis tennis is a really an
incredibly individual sport maybe maybe
the most individualistic sport in the
world
coach major sports I mean when you leave
the locker room we're all by herself
trying to figure it out so Davis Cup is
the team part of that and you know maybe
some of the most fun memories on the
tennis court in Davis Cup playing for
the US you know here in the national
anthem before you play stuff like that
anyways well I was playing I always
thought it was awesome to be a Davis Cup
captain would be so cool eventually you
know just sort of run the shots you
picked the team you put the guys
together you sort of mesh personalities
together right now we have an
interesting mix of personalities where
we've got some older guys in John Isner
and Sam query and Jack sock and guys
have been around for a while and then
we've got some younger players as well
they're coming up in a couple you know
kind of like Ryder Cup style these guys
yeah a little bit and there's only five
guys on the team but yeah I mean that
you know and there's only you know we've
got three young Americans that are 21
and under that are ranked in the top 60
in the world so trying to kind of you
know that's to complete of course
generate do you know different
generations try to put them together and
stuff so it's a lot of fun and then you
know you put together the the physios
and the stringers and the doctors where
we stay all that stuff so you know and
then you do a lot of other stuff as well
you try to promote the game try
the game as much as you can within the
USTA and stuff so it's a not just
competition but it's it's a fun and it's
a it's a heck of a roll for sure well
mix what you're filling in for Rich
Eisen on the Rich Eisen show sitting
here talking to my homie Marty fish is
that the only tennis we haven't so to be
able to think I'm thinking only as a
retired guy right now retired what is it
three years ago now yeah and when you
retired there's such a huge hole in your
heart right there's just something you
were so used to doing each and every day
your routines are different right you
know you're married you've got kids
right we've got to wake up in the
morning now we make breakfast and the
whole nine but for you to be able to
come back in and be part of tennis the
way you are now on the on the US
national level I mean that's got to feel
amazing because it brings you back in
it's tough right I mean you know it is
three years for me as well almost four
years now for me nothing is ever gonna
motivate you the way getting out of bed
and playing that day is for us and
that's what people you know don't really
understand as athletes how they struggle
when they retire it's not right away
right away it was actually nice you know
you same thing you know the same thing
and then you know you can eat whatever
you want stuff with my diet I think my
first meal after a US Open in 2015 was a
five guys and like never even heard of
it it was unbelievable and so I you know
I had like two burgers and a couple
fries and I eaten like that in a long
time years yeah what are we talking
about for a daily what was your average
day like when you were playing yeah in
terms of training and eating yeah I mean
you know look at depending on if it was
an off week or during the week I mean it
you know if it was a tournament week you
know we got to eat and we had to stay up
you had to maintain your calories course
Michael Phelps type stuff we're burning
we're burning as many calories is we
can't eat as many calories as we burn
during a tournament week you know cuz
you're playing and it could be an hour
and a half or it could be four hours
that you're playing miss you know Grand
Slam or or Davis Cup match
you can't burn you can't eat what you're
burning so you're you're just trying to
catch up at that point but when you're
training it's a little different you
know you're totally you can sort of
regiment your your diet as how as far as
how many hours you're training later in
your career you don't practice quite as
much you may do a lot of physical stuff
away from the court because you don't
need quite as much practice stuff so you
know obviously it all obviously depends
so yeah well Nick Swisher's sitting here
talking to Marty fish and I think of you
as you know silver medalists in the
Olympics and all-around good guy great
tennis player but the thing that I
remember you most about now is your golf
game because how do you get so good at
golf playing tennis that's got to be a
Country Club thing I play I play it was
like learning the Gulf is like learning
a language am tennis really like if you
learn it at two or three years old it's
going to be much easier than if you
learn it at 20 or 25 all hands team I
gotta take him to like the local park
throw a hat on we can but I grew up
playing golf I grew up playing golf it
just comes really naturally natural to
me and I love playing it's just I'm at a
point in golf and may sound conceited
but I've come to a point in golf now
where I can't really
tee to green get any better as I never
play I never play I mean I probably
thirty times a year and people think I
play all the time I'm gonna plus two or
plus three and four not gambling
purposes no one ever questions a scratch
by the way you're just okay you're
scratch it's a couple strokes here and
there but you know so I can't get any
better and then I got a practice to get
your short game better and I just never
out of time I feel like just play golf
all it takes too long it's like a
petition you guys were talking about Joe
was mad when I'm gone for advice I
browned last a minute
our she's like where are you and people
that Golf know this and they've they got
a wife at home or a girl at home you get
that text message what hold on what
holder you want tell me you've ever put
the exact I'm on 13 when I'm done but
you know but it takes too long you guys
are talking about baseball and I love
baseball I'm a huge baseball fan i watch
every twins game the I probably watch
158 162 games yeah this year's gonna be
more than a hundred Minnesota Twins
right now and what they're doing over
there special is that to see where
they've kind of come from as an
organization Joe Mauer retires pretty
much the heart and soul of the
organization yeah all of a sudden you
kind of bring over a band of misfits
that no one's really heard of that have
had decent years now a sudden Rocco
Baldelli is taking this team
yeah $15 and then did Molitor get a bad
you know especially the short end of the
stick there because they they had you
know they had a bunch of young guys like
Kepler and Rosario and to know and
Buxton and and and Polanco and these
guys Polanco is leading the league in
batting now you know I think they just
needed a year to go through those and
they still won 75 games it wasn't like
they were like 55 and whatever what they
used to be as well I think they're kind
of a bluff yeah yeah I do and and
obviously the rest of the division is is
what it is so I know there's opportunity
there no doubt about it and they're
taking advantage of it their pitching is
great Barrios is awesome he's a bonafide
ace but like two years ago we played in
Yankee Stadium two years ago when we had
that and Ervin Santana you know they get
up 3-0 and Ervin Santana like walks the
first two guys they're like we didn't
have that guy like a biryeo so that that
you know they could go in there and shut
somebody down I love baseball I'm super
tight with Verlander Justin as well
watch him he put you know a game Yankee
Stadium yesterday's tomorrow yeah every
every time I look up he's seven innings
one or two nine strikeouts I think guys
a joke crazy mix what you're sitting
here talking with Marty fish all-around
good guy and bro let's talk about
Verlander for a hot minute just the fact
that that guy could continue to keep
doing what he's doing them year in and
year out he doesn't get hurt
he's productive I mean I'm her facing
that kid as a rookie in 2006 yeah I mean
he had electric stuff then but I feel
like he's better now yeah I've had the
opportunity over the years to sort of
see the best do what they do not during
the season but kind of in the offseason
when everyone's taking time off I spent
a lot of time in Tampa at Saddle Brook
we actually lived on the same street if
he knew this probably we lived on the
same street in Tampa his sister room
with my wife back here a long time ago
so we but you know so like I trained at
Saddle Brook in Tampa and Jeter was was
trained there and in the offseason only
and he would go 7:30
he was yeah he was living in the same
place as well he would use it up there
7:30 every day in the offseason Justin I
spent a lot of time he's out here in the
offseason and I spent a lot of time with
him that do doesn't miss a day to work
out he'll play golf every day but it's
not it's not until he's done working out
done training you know and and it's it's
it's sometimes he lets me he's again I
played baseball a little bit and like I
love I love baseball we went to UCLA he
was like throwing you know his throwing
program where he just has to keep his
arm going for for 10 minutes a day and
so he let me do it with him a couple of
times I honestly thousand died he throws
so hard and then he goes to the other
side of the of the outfield foul pole to
foul pole yeah long toss dude but it's
not like high balls already it looks
great
like an arrow and I'm catching these
things in my arms flying back I'm seeing
you know I mean I'm seeing 150 mile an
hour served since I was too much you
know since 2000
in hizzoner these guys this thing that
was scared when he's like you know
playing catch then than returning us on
our flank I serve we had a ball feels
like it hurts me you guys get hit by a
pitch or something that doesn't I mean a
tennis ball you can shrug that all but
baseball full-on like squared up with
the tennis I've stepped in there too and
then we went and played a golf
tournament Cabo huh and I probably
shouldn't be saying this but we play
golf tournament Tahoe and Justin and I
were partners and they had a little
baseball field down there at El Dorado
and I got in there and he had a couple
cocktails and he threw the first I guess
it's one of these ones where like they
throw the they'll pitchers will like
kind of do it on purpose and they'll
throw one and he threw one hard over my
head and he wasn't sober and I was like
[Laughter]
the precision of what just seems like
his control he's got it and he threw
that he throws six inches over my head
and I want to take it back to the Davis
Cup only because of myself you know
being a special adviser to Brian Cashman
and being able to work with like our
younger generation of players right I
feel like it's a little different now
coaching younger players and it was when
you and I were growing up yeah you know
just to be able to have that opportunity
to start working with these young kids
how do you go about preparing them for
something that they've never done before
obviously you've been there and done
that
yeah and I've always said it's a lot
easier to listen to somebody who's been
there and done that rather than no one
who's ever been there at all yeah I mean
luckily the respect level is there for
you you know when you get kids I love
helping if anyone calls I pick up and
and we talk tennis any of the young
Americans anytime any day every one of
them knows that it's trying to you know
cuz tennis there's it's not a huge life
expectancy in tennis right so if you go
to college that's you know maybe a year
or two off you're off your career that
you should be getting maybe in the you
know it's
of course I can the prom futures or
challenger levels which is single a and
double-a triple-a of tennis so it's it's
trying to speed up that clock right like
to you know to try to teach these guys
and they're only gonna you can only take
them so far right like two because you
know they can only you can only make
them understand how important the physio
is when you're traveling course but it
costs money and and they don't get that
you gotta spend money on yourself to
make money you know kind of thing just
don't get that you just see it going out
not coming in and they don't see the
long run it's it's realizing that it's
longer than you know just a yearly sort
of thing because it's such a sprint it's
a sprint to get there and once you get
there that's when the journey really
begins yeah yeah and you got a you know
and you got a you know understanding
your diet understanding that in tennis
is Abreu and I heard you saying like I
think you know and you're a baseball guy
so you're gonna stick up for your sport
I'm a tennis guys I'm gonna stick up for
Mom
I think tennis is a harder sport in the
world and here's why because you need to
be really good at your craft in every
sport you need to be physically fit
mostly in every sport and I say mostly
because golfy problem and and and you
need to be as mentally tough as all
three of those and in tennis
if you're not good at your craft you're
not gonna be any good if you're not
physically fit as physically fit as you
are good at your craft you're not gonna
make it and then if you're not as
mentally tough so it's so hard to create
that tennis player to create a top 20 or
top their even top 50 in the world
player because outside of the United
States it's a really popular sport it's
soccer yeah it's tennis I mean in Europe
I mean it's a European dominated sport
right now so we're like Federer and
Nadal and Djokovic and Murray and these
guys that I played with you know so so
it's a massive sport over there and and
Australia and you go to these places
like you're going over to to London and
when you go on you by the way so they're
so like Wimbledon starting on I know I
was gonna say we wouldn't coming up very
much a gust of tennis so you
see in the papers that they'll have some
stuff written up on baseball and that'll
be really cool to have especially those
two teams there but dude it dominates
tennis dominates over the overall life
Wimbledon's huge over there at this time
of the year and so it's you know so my
point is there's a lot of people playing
tennis and to create that player to
create that sort of player where their
top 50 in top 30 and even top 10 in the
world it ain't easy Wow
you're the best bro come on ladies
gentlemen check out my man Marty fish on
twitter at Marty fish once again Marty
fish all-around good guy the best bro
thank you so much for coming in let's
get out there and hustle some fools on
that Marty fish brother thank you for
coming off for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel - 39 on
DIRECTV
for free on be our live or download the
Rich Eisen show app